all right yell let's move on to our
first guest you know her from the
blockbuster Jurassic world movies as
well as many others that I love like the
village she's the daughter of director
Ron Howard and like her famous fathers
she recently moved behind the camera for
a documentary on dads let's welcome
Bryce Dallas Howard everybody hello I
love you and I'm very excited that
you're here
so where are you right now it looks very
relaxing I know I'm in New York oh and
there's a I'm in upstate New York and
there's a there's a like a backdrop and
then behind this is just like garage
that's awesome all of us have ours and
this is like my living room and they
just put a set in it so yeah oh my god
it's like even more fake for TV it's
awesome well before I forget
congratulations this is really awesome
you're officially a college graduate
that's amazing that you went back nobody
does that
I you know what I did I kind of never
really left school and my my teachers
like when I when I was taking a leave of
absence to start working until I do the
village and stuff like that I kept
saying to my teachers I'm like I'm gonna
come back I'm gonna come back I'm gonna
come back and right away I started
taking classes at an accredited
university in order to transfer to
eventually graduate I didn't think it
was gonna take me 21 years he's been a
little busy making huge successful
movies so yeah nothing they need to be
huge and successful but they are so
that's that's okay I just think it's
awesome like my mom's a teacher so when
I told her I wasn't going to college and
I was gonna be a waitress living on a
mattress to be a singer it wasn't the
best thing she'd ever heard she wasn't
very excited about the notion so it
worked out luckily but how do you
celebrate coz so many things like I had
my birthday in quarantine everybody's
had like moments anniversaries stuff
like that happening according seen how
did you celebrate graduating do you know
what it was it was
really kind of amazing like my parents
got one of those things one of those
signs that you can like like put in the
grass in front of your house it's like
like congratulations graduate rice or
whatever a graduate and um and I had a
my husband sent off this thing called
like tribute where you can just like
record tributes for people and so he
sent it to like all of my friends and
family and folks that I've known for
ever and ever and ever and they all
recorded videos just you know being
lovely and congratulate you mean so
that's really sweet I had my daughter
Katie and she was about I know 10 months
old something like that just kind of
holding her over my head and I was
smiling I had my my mouth wide open and
she had her mouth wide open and then she
she vomited in a in a forceful column I
guess they call it projectile vomiting
directly into like it hit my oval oh it
just went right into my throat and of
course your reaction is to throw this
person you know as far away from you as
possible but I didn't I held on to her I
just spit as much of it as I could out
and that's when I realized I was a dad
Arielle I'm back with Bryce Dallas
Howard that was a look at her new
documentary dads which is out on Apple
TV Plus tomorrow so y'all gotta check it
out but Bryce your new movie is a
different take on being a dad can you
tell me a little about it and who's in
it
yeah so um so this is a documentary
called dads and it's a celebration of
modern fathering around the globe so we
I got to interview all different kinds
of dads comedian dads I have this
perspective that stand-up comedians are
our modern-day philosophers and and I
wanted to profile
I called him hero dad's hero dads from
around the world and um and that was
sort of like the combination between the
two and then during the course of making
the movie I kept saying all we need to
profile
dad who's an expecting father someone
who hasn't had a kid yet and then
becomes a father during the course of
the movie and I kept not finding and I
was about halfway through shooting and
then found out that my brother and his
wife we're gonna have their first child
and so I was like okay I got my
expecting dad so there is an aspect of
the movie that is kind of the Howard
story plan that to have your family be
as big of a part as they ended up
playing no no I kind of like early on I
sort of mentioned the possibility to my
dad you know be great if because my
grandfather had recently passed away and
I had filmed interview with him several
years prior and I was like well maybe
maybe I can go back and watch my that
interview and see if there's anything a
value to time you know but my dad was
like no honestly he was so nervous about
it and he he just you know and I think
his concerns are were fair um he's like
who we've lived for over 16 years as a
private-public family why would we want
it's really incredibly hard yeah yeah
and we've been lucky in that regard
um why why peek behind the curtain now
uh but uh but with my brother being the
expecting father um it just like I said
it just made sense and so um and so my
dad when he finally saw the film he was
like okay I understand well what made
him a great dad because this is this is
an awesome thing cuz not all of us I'm
one of them I didn't grow up with a
great dad and I but i but I love hearing
about how people did and I have my you
know one of my best friends is also my
assistant and she had a great dad and my
nanny has a great dad and I love hearing
that because it's also you know
something for people that didn't have
fathers to kind of know how to set the
bar for what they should be expecting
for a father for their children or as a
husband or so how was your debt what
made him a great dad because he had to
have been really busy right um you know
what he he was very present and he
figured out my parents together figured
out given their life situation how to be
present and it looks different for every
single family in
like everyone has a lot of plates that
they're spinning and and it's different
for every individual and so um what that
looked like in terms of my childhood was
we were just traveling you know my mom
would like figure it out so that all
four kids we could go wherever my dad
was going and we would enroll in local
schools and or get homeschooled and wow
it's almost like touring musicians it's
almost like how a lot of musicians bring
their kids on the road and face road yes
that's exactly exactly it and it was
awesome because I loved it and my
parents figured out pretty early that
they could really control me by
threatening that I wouldn't be allowed
to go to set if I didn't make myself
yeah oh yeah
eyes for you Oh rice for you yes a video
was sent to us just for you here here we
go we're gonna play it hey Kelly well
let's see an embarrassing story about
Bryce she was a great kid and she loved
visiting the set and she was very very
helpful in fact by the time she was 11
or 12
she was actually pitching in as like a
production assistant in in fact she was
she was so efficient that she was
finally given the responsibility of
having a walkie talkie you know so that
the production assistants could talk to
one another and give direction and and
and guidance and and I mean that was
that was a real honor and a show of you
know of appreciation for how much her
she was it was great the first day she
was terrific she was on it the second
day was good too except suddenly over
the walkie talkie
we heard Bryce ordering the extras
holding area to be moved from one side
of a building over to the other now now
granted she was trying to get it out of
the Sun and into the shade and her
thinking was pretty good but it's not
quite cool to have the 12 year old
taking over the production so she lost
her walkie-talkie that day but I knew
that one day she'd want to be behind the
scenes calling the shots
and she does it really well oh my gosh
that's amazing
don't you take personal responsibility I
like and you know it I know but it's
there's something to that even that
moment is a 12 year old like I think
there are moments for everyone that's
truly successful there are those moments
whatever that walkie-talkie moment is
for people but you're truly successful
because at the very beginning even if it
was one person they told you that you
were amazing and you could do anything
you wanted and you believed them and I
think that those the moments that you're
so bold and you're like well I got this
I can do this who cares that I'm 12 like
I think that that's you know kind of
what makes you you and what makes you
special and kind of a light and what you
do but thank you so much Bryson thanks
for calling in congratulations again on
graduating that super Cole subscribe to
my channel subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel subscribe to my
channel please don't make me keep going